[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui s'est dit mais ici oui
alors il scénarise capucines dans
l'émission tout à l'heure a reconnu mais
qu'elle avait vécu une très belle
histoire de trois quatre mois à aa avec
kev jusqu'à la fusion elle est tellement
une très belle très belle histoire
d'amour which amené beaucoup de
sentiments et puis malheureusement il ay
la haye après il évacuer vers d'autres
aventures
la voilà je trouve ça plutôt bien
expliqué ouais c'est ça moi j'ai une
autre version
[Rires]
c'est vrai que quoi ils vous étiez un
oui c'est vrai ça et je me suis vraiment
ça moche quoi ils savaient quelque chose
comme ça et vous êtes resté copan pas
bien bien sûr il s'entend bien avec
votre nouveau fiancé d'accord t'as bien
des rêves wen mais ce qui est très
mignon c'est qu'un jour dans la loge du
magal est venu me voir elle m'a dit
voilà c'est fini et tout mais
franchement et manqué je regrette mon
histoire avec ce qu'elle m'avait 10,3 à
minot ratman ne regrette plus est très
amoureux alors est ok vous avez tous moi
j'avais gâte